cette semaine notre coup de coeur et de
film france réalisé par françois ozon
avec paula bear et pierre niney au
lendemain de la guerre 14 18 dans une
petite ville allemande anna se rend tous
les jours sur la tombe de son fiancé 30
morts sur le front en france mais ce
jour là un jeune français adrien est
venu se recueillir sur la tombe de son
ami allemand
cette présence à la suite de la défaite
allemande va provoquer des réactions
passionnelles dans la ville le
réalisateur de huit femmes nous
bouleverse dans son nouveau film un mélo
historique qui se déroule juste après la
guerre 14-18 france est un film intense
et rapide d'une densité inouïe
l'interprétation est précise et la mise
en scène élégante le spectateur tombera
sous la séduction de paul à bir jeune
actrice allemande et véritable
révélation du film pierre niney trouve
l'un de ses meilleurs rôles
le film est l'une des plus grandes
réussites de françois ozon france est
incontestablement la sensation de la
rentrée et est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe noiret